Is there any rife program to use that will help eliminate glyphosate from my system?
No, there's not
or say, so there's not a rife frequency that will
pull glyphosate out of your body
nor is there a rife frequency that will pull mercury out of your body or pull micotoxins out of your body.
That's not how a frequency
from a light source is going to work. Is there rife frequencies in your program already that
will help with your liver detoxification process? Yes, I put that in everybody's program
in your overnight program already.
And we've had that question ask, what rife program can I run to help me detoxify?
Well, there isn't a rife detoxification program per se.
Again, the rife machete is best to kill pathogens to stimulate your organs, because it works
on living things. To kill cancer cells, it's working on living things. It's not going to pull
stuff out of your body. So that's where you have to use a tool the best way it is.
Meaning you're running liver frequencies. That's in again, what I said, and everybody's overnight
program already. Or you know, that's really all you could do. So you're stimulating your liver to
work better. Remember, your liver is in your kidney, which those two frequencies, those sets of
frequencies are in everybody's program. It's going to help you with the process of detoxification.
Remember, go back to seven phases of detoxification. Course to really understand how detoxification
is and how it works, because I think there's a lot of mythical things about detoxification,
like there's some sort of magic detox that I'm going to do that's going to get rid of
XYZ toxin. And I'm going to not have that in my body anymore. That is just not true. That's not
how physiology works. So you have to be eliminating phase six and detoxification. You have to be
poopy to the toilet and pee to the toilet. That's how you're going to ultimately get things out of
your body. That and sweating. So using the sauna is going to help because you're bypassing the
gut and the kidneys by using the sauna. You're sweating. You need things that are being dumped into the
small intestine and then moving to the colon. You want them to stay there and not be reabsorbed
in the colon. So you're using a binder. I have almost everybody on a binder. So there's nothing
else you have to do there. So if you're not having a good bowel movement at least one every day,
you're already toxifying yourself. You're already behind the eight ball. Well, how do I do that?
Well, you start taking magnesium at night. Oh, hello. Let's start doing the coffee
animals. So getting into our coffee animals, doing coffee animals is one of the greatest ways
that you can detox because it's going to help you eliminate. It's going to help your intestinal transit
time speedups so that you're not reabsorbing things dealing with phase five. It's going to help your
gallbladder dealing with phase four. It's going to help your liver dealing with phase one, two,
three. So coffee animal is your best overall detoxification tool. And then you're working on
keylating to pull things out of the tissue into the blood and glyphosate are in your tissues
and we're trying to get them into the blood. So we can get them into the liver and the kidneys and
get them into the toilet. So look back at that seven phases of detox to help understand the process
and then we'll, you know, we're going to be out the right track.